ميسي ينافس مبابي وبنزيما على لقب الافضل
ورونالدو في نزال الحقيقه والعاب الاطفال
تزين ملعب فودافون ارينا هذه الاخبار
وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
تعرض جيك بول لاول خساره في مسيرته
الحديثه بالملاكمه على يد تومي فيوري في
نزال الدرعيه بالسعوديه تحت انظار نجم كره
القدم كريستيانو رونالدو وبطل الملاكمه
السابق
وتفوق نجم تلفزيون الواقع البريطاني على
منافسه الامريكي صانع المحتوى الشهير
بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في اراء الحكام
بنزال الحقيقه في الدرعيه
انظار عشاق كره القدم اليوم نحو العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس لمتابعه حفل جوائز الافضل
في استفتاء فيفا للعام 2022
وللمره الخامسه عشره يظهر النجم
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي في القائمه
النهائيه للمرشحين للفوز والى جانبه كل من
كريم بنزيما وكليان مبابي
ما عوده الدوري التركي الى الحياه اثر
التوقف بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
مؤخرا عرفت العوده لقطات انسانيه رائعه من
جانب الجماهير واللاعبين تجاه ضحايا
الزلزال حيث توقفت المباراه في الدقيقه
الرابعه وسبعه عشره ثانيه مباراه في
الدوري التركي بالطبع وهي الساعه التي ضرب
فيها الزلزال تركيا وقامت الجماهير بالقاء
اعداد كبيره من الدمى الى ارض الملعب بهدف
توزيعها على الاطفال الناجين
[موسيقى]
حجره ورقه مقص تحدد مقعد راموس في طائره
هكذا خطف النجم الاسباني مقعد الطائره
المطل على الشباك من زميلها الفرنسيه
مبابي وهما في طريقهما الى مارسيليا امس
لخوض مباراه بالدور الفرنسي انتهت بفوز
باريس سان جيرمان بثلاثه اهداف نظيفه سجل
منهما مبابي هدفين